oh it's surreal what's happened in my
life in the last few years
um you know i think part of me always
was tickled by the idea of some day i
create characters that people would
do parodies of in magazine or whatever
um and indeed i got a little of that
when i was on the tv show beauty the
beast because they once had linda
hamilton as a
as a guest host and she did a skit about
vincent and catherine and you know those
were i didn't create those characters
but i wrote about them so i feel all
my characters are being parodied on
saturday night live that was very cool
uh but then what's surreal about this is
it's
it's not my character's being credited
on saturday live it's it's
me uh and that was pretty
strange and south park was was stranger
still i love south park i'm glad
they were relatively gentle with me you
know when i tell you you're gonna be in
south park and
you remember what they've done to like
tom cruise or barbra streisand
you live in terror but they were they
were they were
relatively gentle with me um i will say
that
and i've said this before they got one
thing wrong really really
badly wrong i don't know why they want
it you know that the south park me
has this obsession with wieners
and anyone who knows me whoever has
watched my show knows that my actual
obsession
is with boobies
[Applause]
from beginning